all right
here we go
smod castle in new jersey and scum and
villainy in l.a
you guys make some noise for kevin smith
mark bernardin
fat man beyond coast to coast
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh hello
[Applause]
welcome to fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith and i am mark bernardin hey
holy [ __ ] this is the most technically
complicated version of the show we've
ever done
i'm not sure why but yeah i guess we're
still doing it hold on let me get in the
middle i'm so used to like leaving you
space because you're supposed to love
that i thought it was adorable
but now you can take center stage man
i think i'd like to dip my balls in it
it's such a bricky symmetry with you in
the middle it's a beautiful shot ah
right down the middle how is los angeles
uh it's warm it's lovely the crowd here
is adorable
oh
[Applause]
my dick is bigger
i uh let me share something with you my
friend i um
today you know i've been hiking
i haven't for a while now two months and
uh today was the 69th
hike which like when i started this i
was like i'm gonna try to do as many
days in a row as i can and then then i
was like well i've done 10 maybe i can
get to 37 that's a marketable number
and then after that it was like well 50
is close and that's a cool number and
then after 50 it was like well come on
you got to get to 69.
so i got to 69 i've been putting up a
photo on twitter every time i've done it
and stuff so
for the 69th photo
i was like what do i put up man like i
don't have there's no runion background
like i'd put up
a photo of me with twin lights the day
before and i realized it's so phallic i
should have used that as day 69
but i hadn't so
i got this idea in my head i was like oh
[ __ ] i'm walking in my hometown
of highlands new jersey i am in the same
place where i had my first 69.
this like in los angeles i could go to
the place where i had my last 69.
but here man is like gives you a
milestone so i was like oh i'm gonna go
take a picture in front of my home
address in front of 21 jackson street
the house i grew up in
um and the whole time i was like
it's going to be creepy
when the people who live in the house
find out later on like you know i'm sure
they've seen me i'm sure when they got
the house people are like you know who
used to live here right and [ __ ] like
that i know they were aware of me and my
connection
to the house
um and all summer long while we were
making clerks i would go park in front
of the house and do my hike starting
from there including even stepping into
the gravel driveway you know as if i was
leaving my house or something and i was
sure that they must have seen me over
the course of those few months and even
if they didn't know who i was or what
connection i had to the house they
thought he lost a bunch of weight you
know because they watched me come for
many days and [ __ ] like that
so but this would be different i'm going
to put up their house and make a 69
comment and [ __ ] like that so i was a
little worried about what would happen
i get to the house to take a picture
family
that lives there
they're out in the yard having a
celebration the day before which was
saturday highlands had their st
patrick's day parade three days later
which you know a lot of people like well
that's [ __ ] highlands for you but
it's not about that you have your parade
three days after st patrick's day
you are open to far more marching bands
you know who do that very specific
irish thing you know that bagpipey [ __ ]
so
they that makes sense like and
apparently highlands has been doing uh
st patrick's day parade for like a good
15 years or more i grew up in this town
we never had a parade like that never
like there was no [ __ ] saint pat
i'm i'm staying in highlands like i got
an airbnb right like ironically on snug
harbor which is across the street from
the rec center where i met jason muse
and walt and brian stuff
and that was the staging area for the
beginning of the [ __ ] parade so i
opened up my [ __ ] curtains on
saturday morning
there's a sea of [ __ ] teenagers
wearing like my high school band uniform
and i was the drum major when i was a
kid i was the guy with the big hat that
did this but the big [ __ ] stick and
[ __ ]
so you know i
smoke right before i go to bed and i
usually wake up three hours later so i
woke up blaze looked out saw that and
was like i gotta get my hat
and then it took me a minute to process
it's not about you anymore that was like
38 years ago or something says [ __ ] move
on
so i saw them and i saw like a bunch of
policemen marching bands that i guess
they're predominantly irish naturally
makes sense um with instruments and [ __ ]
like that buses
ten thousand people descended on
highlands man for a st patrick's day
parade
two days after st patrick's day and
they're like it's like this every year
it's [ __ ] amazing and [ __ ] so
i'm i'm in highlands already
i'm like you know i just finished my
hike let's take a picture in front of
the [ __ ] house i go to 20 on jackson
street the house i grew up in there's
the family out in front of the house i'd
been there the day before for st
patrick's day as i mentioned and i drove
past and they'd shut my block down
to have a street fair to have a little
like block party like out of a john
hughes movie i was so [ __ ] charmed by
this because like i grew up there and it
was like growing up in a penitentiary
like [ __ ] everyone locked their [ __ ]
up and [ __ ] no don't go out on the
street what are you crazy as if we lived
in some crime infested area or something
like that these cats literally had like
stanchions up on each end of the block
and 21 jackson street my old home
address that was the host station beer
[ __ ] like grill going on it was so
[ __ ] charming so when i went today to
take the picture the family was outside
and i've seen them once or twice when
i've walked in front of the house and
[ __ ] but i never wanted to bother them
or creep them out like do you know who i
am
so
today i'm walking by and i see them out
there and i'm like oh [ __ ] like i can't
take this
69 picture now
because they're gonna be like what the
[ __ ] are you doing and [ __ ] and so
the woman the mom
makes eye contact with me and i nod and
she nods and i'm on the other side of
the street and then i'm like you know
what [ __ ] it like just go over and
[ __ ] say hi
and so i was like hi and she was like
you're kevin smith and i was like oh
yeah sometimes i am i
how are you and she was like oh my god
like we live in your house i was like
yes i know i know get out no
she was so sweet that she introduced me
the kids and her she had some friends
there as well and then she introduced me
to her husband they come from like
colt's neck um and they'd never really
lived down the shore before and then now
they're like we wouldn't live any place
else and [ __ ] it's the exact same house
i grew up in but because of hurricane
sandy they had to raise the house so
it's elevated by like 15 feet or
something whereas in when i grew up in
it it was down on the ground
so
they go
do you want to go inside
and i was like more than anything in the
world like i'm a middle-aged stoner yes
i want to go in the house i grew up in
[ __ ] yes
they took me in to my house she did the
wife
and i got to tour
my childhood home you got to understand
i was there to make a dirty sex joke on
twitter
but instead i had this real like [ __ ]
what dreams may come walk through my
past i walked in a house mark that was
mine but was not mine at all it had the
shape
of of the
of the house that i grew up in but like
way better furnishings like these people
got money and taste and you know that
right away was foreign i walked in i was
like this is not the house i grew up in
holy [ __ ] where's the plastic on the
couch and [ __ ] like that
um the master bedroom is now my bedroom
what used to be my bedroom is now the
master bedroom and [ __ ] which to be fair
when i lived there i always considered
the master bedroom anyway um what was my
parents room as a little girl's room and
then a little boy has my sister's uh
room their bathroom looks way [ __ ]
better their kitchen's way nicer
but when i went into the kitchen
the uh
mrs reilly the name of the family that
lives there is the rileys hence they
really celebrated st patrick's day
that's why they closed down the block
and [ __ ] i was like i saw the block was
closed down he goes we're the riley's
you know i was like i got you so um
she took me into the kitchen and she's
like i don't think anything
is a left from the house and i i know
she's right because before they ever got
near it when it was still like the husk
after the flood
we went in there me and my brother and
sister and everything was wiped like you
couldn't [ __ ] see anything they even
looked like a house it was all [ __ ]
beams and
[ __ ] then the lady goes
but i think these windows
might have been yours and i looked at
these windows and they were
the windows that i'll never forget this
like my parents
debated about getting these windows for
[ __ ] months and had discussions about
like well ultimately it'll save money on
heating bills and [ __ ] like that making
getting these kitchen windows replaced
was such a
[ __ ] huge moment in my pre-teen life
and as i pull up to the [ __ ] handle
it's literally those [ __ ] windows and
now they're not modern anymore they're
you know [ __ ] 30 years old at this
point [ __ ] but it's the same [ __ ]
handle that i remember the old ones went
away and these new ones came in and i
remember thinking like this is nothing
like my house
now it's the only thing left to my
[ __ ] house so i'm looking and she's
like are these your windows and i look
at the handles and i just start bawling
you know i'm like oh my god and she's
just like what did those handles do to
you
um it was so [ __ ] sweet then we went
outside and they'd let me go in the
garage my sister when we were kids
virginia my mom and dad went to a
vacation without us they went to hawaii
and it was like 1981 or 82. one of the
only times they ever went away without
us kids and so when they went away my
sister spray painted the inside back
wall of the garage these two caricatures
of my parents going on vacation in
hawaii [ __ ] piece is still up there
man they put stuff in front of it
they're not like you know look we've
left it on display but they were like we
didn't have the heart to take it down
it's so good you did a good job i was
like oh my my sister actually painted
that they're like well if we knew that
we would have taken it down
we just keep telling people you painted
it i was like go ahead even though it
says virginia at the bottom and stuff
but um then we went down the street and
[ __ ] took a picture with them and the
kids and whatnot and they were like you
come by any [ __ ] time and [ __ ] and i
have the heart to tell them that i was
like i'm gonna take you up on that like
left and right i would love to go to my
old house
sit in my old bedroom and write you know
what i'm saying like [ __ ] how trippy
would that be especially because my old
bedroom is their master bedroom so i'd
be sitting on their bed and [ __ ] while
they're watching tv
[Music]
what do you think dante would say now
what are you guys doing um
you would force an airbnb on them you'd
be like listen i need you to leave
here's a thousand dollars
yes
these cats look like they're doing well
because believe me during the summer
like we rented a house in middletown to
live in while we were shooting the movie
and i walked you know every day i went
to highlands to walk and i always parked
in front of my house and i was like why
didn't i just knock on these cats door
and offer them whatever we were paying
to rent the house in middletown they
maybe they weren't in the business
market to do that but if some stranger
comes to your door it's like we'll give
you a [ __ ] whatever it is
to rent your [ __ ] house this is legit
i made clerks you might be like all
right yeah just don't [ __ ] make
clerks in it or whatever but
but um but now that i've met them like
it wouldn't have played man because they
like dug in like ticks they got a family
that that also made me incredibly
emotional
i saw the little boy running around in
the backyard
and like for one brief moment i was like
kid i know your whole [ __ ] future
i know what's going to happen to you
well me but i know what's going to
happen like that's [ __ ] up i see in me
running around and [ __ ] in the
backyard it was really nuts man so it's
been a good trip we did a
um clerks 2 live here at smod castle uh
on friday we had a poker tournament here
at spot castle on saturday we did that
kevin smith club
state of the union event right before
this and now we're getting the stream uh
fat man beyond which is uh great because
it allows me to bring
uh mark bernardin right into the heart
of leonardo lazy give it up for the
great mark bernard
i'm i'm surprised kev that as lovely as
that story was
that you didn't go down to the garden
state parkway at exit 69 and then take
your 69 picture
[Laughter]
it's like right there dude
god damn it man see you're such a better
writer than i am and that's normally
about things with plot and three-act
structure i should have thought that's a
dirty [ __ ] pun there's no way i
shouldn't have thought of like go to
exit 69. and i didn't [ __ ] think of
that but you know what i'm doing for day
70.
doing exactly that how are you my friend
how has your week been um i'm i'm good
not nearly as uh as recontourish as you
are i didn't really do anything this
week that is is is requiring of a long
story
um
i spent most of this week in and out of
the hospital i'm the only modifier
you're going to throw in front of that
not long but cute yeah
cute
yeah no i i might
my kid has uh my autistic daughter
also has epilepsy which awesome found
that out during the pandemic and so
right you only found out during the
pandemic yeah yeah first ever seizure
was like july 20th of 2020 um which was
a surprise now a for life thing it is
now a for life thing
um so we were in the children's hospital
of la for the week to do a sort of
battery of tests to figure out all right
what do these seizures look like like
she was she had like their head sock
that had a bunch of electrodes and [ __ ]
in it and so she spent the week well
monday through friday
in the hospital so
i don't have any like i did cool fun
[ __ ] i was like i ate bad hospital food
for some of it um i drove more than i've
driven since the pandemic back and forth
to
sort of downtown l.a
um
i watched some movies i guess because i
had some time to kill
what have you seen um i saw turning red
the new pixar movie
did you like it it's wonderful
it is so it's it's
and i think you'll appreciate it is that
it's very specific in its time in its
place and that it takes place in like
2002 in toronto and it's about this
young asian woman who's sort of coming
of age and part of her coming of age is
she turns into a
red panda that's giant and may or may
not crush things because she doesn't
know her own strength triggered by
emotion to show you how self-involved i
am yeah number one i'm cutting you off
to tell you how unself-involved i am
tell yourself involved and the fact that
you were like it's very specific takes
place in toronto in 2002. the first
thought went through my head was like i
was alive then and in toronto i could be
in this movie
uh this is the movie about uh periods
right more or less um much more than
that but that's the metaphor here right
that is the metaphor is that here's a
young woman named milin who was coming
of age and is not expecting that part of
coming of age will come with this giant
red thing
um it happens to be a panda it's
manifested as a panda but it's also very
candidly about periods like all of her
friends like did you get your period do
you need pads to do whatever and it's
it's lovely in the way that it is again
both about about adolescence and it's
about what it's like to be
um a young woman who's in love with boy
bands and is deep into her friend circle
who has a giant thing crash into it that
she doesn't know what to do about
you know as well as it's like
it's it is a wonderful story about
familial expectation
and about how it and and the pressures
on a person to live up to what their
parents and their family expect them to
be
um and it's and it's funny because i saw
that and then i saw the trailer for ms
marvel which also is wonderful and
lovely and i cannot wait for [ __ ]
miss marvel to show up but it also has
that feeling of
here's a young woman pakistani living in
new jersey who is like there are
familial expectations for her and can
she live up to what they expect her to
be or can she be more
and and it was this kind of little
kismet thing between watching the
trailer in that movie and then being in
the hospital and feeling all of these
things about you know daughters and
growing up and
yeah so i i would much rather have
preferred go to my childhood house and
take dirty pictures but
they weren't [ __ ] dirty man they
would have been if they weren't home
they would have been [ __ ] dirty
yes
you're so [ __ ] right
um i've been seeing uh your uh book
being retweeted quite often this week
from a number
of reputable [ __ ] sources
i appreciate the reputable and the
disreputable i will take every source
did you get a gaming
tweet um neil gaiman he gave me a blurb
for the book um so so right on the front
cover which i actually have here
because it'll be a giveaway item for the
q a we do today
ah
yes only for los angeles only yeah sorry
guys you know not as if kev has a comic
book store
[Laughter]
we have to organize these things in
advance man
we have a giveaway though do you
macdonald did this beautiful print
of me and you i'm depicted wearing elvis
gear excellent you're depicted burning
the last picture he drew of us together
nice that you were lazer fair about it's
a wonderful piece i've signed the mall
and everybody leaving smod castle
tonight everyone's getting one of these
not just one lucky person everyone
yeah sorry it's it's thunderdome in here
like we actually make a person do a
thing
you're welcome
we i believe we have bills to pay we do
have some bills to pay we got a couple
of ads i figure we'll do one here and
then one after the news perhaps let's do
that and then i'll tell you about
something i watch
yeah it's the highland st patrick's day
parade
oh my god top of the morning to you mark
jingle bro erin go braless it was that
[ __ ] a while can you make the noise of
the bagpipes again so it sounds like
you're getting on the internet in 1992.
[Music]
that was the bagpipes that's the
bagpipes looking at the internet in 1992
how is how are we holding up so far jc
banff man jump on in here
and he probably can't right because he's
in the back room i don't know
i have a here we'll try this you guys
won't be able to see i have a webcam
from like
20 years ago
we can't see you but i'm gonna
count you in so everyone here could at
least applaud for your presence right
okay
one two three banff man ladies and
gentlemen bam
i ha i have a the people at home can see
i have this webcam from like 20 years
ago that's broadcasting at like 10
frames 8 frames a second so i'm like a
slideshow
but my audio is clean uh but so far so
good i can't believe it
i feel like we're in the future
yeah i like how we were like yeah let's
do this by coastal uh [ __ ]
episode of the podcast without ever
having done it having no idea how to do
it but yeah let's put up [ __ ] tickets
let's sell some [ __ ]
well we did a version of it you were
just home and i was here right we just
zoomed
yeah yeah but this one is uh you with
people and me with people oh that's so
sweet
it needs two venues on both sides of the
[ __ ] country
neither then you bigger than 60 seats
the uh the tricky part is getting
the audio in the room
and
like
not creating a feedback loop between
smod castle and the broadcast and scum
and villainy which we achieved
somebody fishing for a compliment
magically
magically we achieved my job everything
um
you're doing amazing buddy buddy buddy
buddy buddy
i'm faking a feedback loop
i know i i got the joke yes
great it's killing in la i'll just tell
you that
um you got the ad cop yeah i don't i'm
at a loss here i do
um so i'm going to get into it
our first ad is brought to you by good
people at curiositystream
give it up for the good people of
curiosity stream
a subscription streaming service that
offers thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers including
exclusive originals curiosity
let's acknowledge the fact that like uh
what is it read that sentence again
curiosity stream is a subscription
streaming service
that offers thousands of documentaries
and non-fiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers including
exclusive originals
all right number one what a brilliant
idea number two
thank god that's what you applauded for
before you found out what it was
everyone was applauding it could have
been like you know what's it called
again
curiosity stream curiosity stream is a
racist think tank you know what it is
mercifully they're offering a service
that we can all [ __ ] get behind man
explain this curiosity stream mr mark
bernard curiosity stream is the netflix
for nerds the hulu for history buffs the
disney plus for the scientists in us
curiosity stream is also extremely
affordable at just under 20 a year
that's a dollar sixty seven a month
come on learn some [ __ ] for less than
two bucks a month
i look that price has to be very
accurate my streaming my curiosity all
over the place that's cheap as [ __ ]
that's cheap as [ __ ] what about getting
for a buck 67 a month it's the
entertainment brand for people who want
to know more it's the world's first
streaming service addressing our
lifelong quest to learn explore and
understand it's available on a ton of
platforms there's a web app roku android
xbox one smart tvs and ios oh also
chromecast amazon fire amazon kindle and
apple tv
it's available worldwide and content
spans science nature history technology
music and sports and it's adding new
shows every week
check you out so it must be aggregating
a bunch of old things and new things
together i think it's it's a bunch of
catalog stuff as well as i think they're
commissioning new documentaries all the
time there's a lot to learn kev
[ __ ] always is man he's got a good
point ladies and gentlemen he's a good
not only a good writer very wise man
wizard mark bernard indeed i read with
the best of them so go to
curiositystream.com fat man for
unlimited access to the world's top
documentaries and non-fiction series and
for our fans use promo code fatman and
you'll save 20
off which comes out to only 14.99 a year
so click the link or go to less than a
dollar 67 a month it is because of us
because of us we just want to be smarter
people we know people we know people so
go to curiositystream.com
fatman and save 25
right now that's only 14.99 for the
whole year a dollar 25 a month they even
did the math for us because they know we
can't add or subtract or divide
yeah so i mean like listen you got a
bunch of other streaming services i know
you do for a dollar 25 a month compared
to the 1999 you're spending over there
and the 1499 spinning over there learn
some [ __ ]
oh my god what a great pitch way to
[ __ ] back him into a corner and [ __ ]
hey
stupid buy this learn some [ __ ] damn it
i think that should be their tagline get
smart stupid uh we thank the good folks
at curiositystream for
sponsoring the first half of tonight's
episode of fat man beyond give it up for
curiosity stream
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so what did you watch kev you said you
watched a thing
somebody on twitter
was like have you seen fresh
um they yes you a [ __ ] kid and we're
gonna talk about how good it is they
said have you seen fresh it reminded me
of tusk
and i was like
i've never heard that before other than
other than you know the [ __ ] uh human
centipede
nobody's ever said you know what tusk
reminds me of like no no nobody what i
always hope they'll say is tusk reminds
me of uh misery because it has the same
structure as misery it's not all that
different when you think about it except
one guy is not a writer he's a podcaster
and lady turns him into a walrus as a
guy so if again you know
but um
the uh barely a difference
yes barely barely any difference so
somebody said you you got it reminded me
of tusk
and so i was like i gotta [ __ ] look
into it and it's on hulu i think
it's on hulu um fresh it stars sebastian
stan the winter soldier
[ __ ] uh
tommy of pam and tommy he of the
animatronic talking dick
um
and who is the young lady she's relative
newcomer i i didn't know it was directed
by
a first timer somebody pull up uh
that was the director
the actress daisy edgar jones she's
british
yeah but she's playing american in this
she's convincing american man because i
was watching her going like who is this
young american actress and i was like oh
she's british um
the director's name somebody pulled that
for me please i should remember thinking
what is it
mimi cave
her first feature i believe
[ __ ] stunning
it's
i don't i i just i don't want to [ __ ]
spoil it for you but i think in order to
get you there
i got to give you some deets about it i
would
go as clean as i did but like
it might take a bit of a sell the movie
is [ __ ] phenomenal
and i watch it with my wife who's about
as hardcore feminist as it gets
and this is a movie about victimization
and there's a woman being victimized and
my wife hates [ __ ] like that she's like
i don't need to watch another [ __ ]
thing where some woman's tied up and
blah blah i was like i get it i get it
go in the other room
um
so you know when we're sit down to watch
this it starts as a like uh a meat cube
as a no i wouldn't say a rom-com but
like more like a film
indie film about two people gonna find
love in the big city
and within the first 20 minutes kind of
like tusk
something [ __ ]
somebody turns real [ __ ] hard
and the movie becomes something
completely different so when the movie
shifted and became you know a [ __ ]
hostage type movie a captive movie
um and the you know spoilers the main
female character is [ __ ] in prison
instantly my wife was like turn this
[ __ ] off and i was like it was made it
was written by a woman it was directed
by a woman i think i saw a lot of women
producers like i
don't bail yet like i know [ __ ] looks
bad but like i think there's a curveball
coming man i think you want to hang out
for this
and she was delighted that she did
because the movie spares it's not like
you know oh it's made by a woman so it's
not as [ __ ] hard as it could be or
something it just doesn't do the [ __ ]
that my wife's like i've seen that a
zillion times this movie was able to do
something i've never seen before and i
could not take my [ __ ] eyes off of it
it is so [ __ ] captivating and it is
brutal
um it captures your imagination it
awakens every [ __ ] nightmare you've
ever had
um
i'm trying to stay away from the word
that'll really sell it
but it's about cannibalism
didn't see that coming
well whoever went mmm is the person to
be suspected
cannibalism
well there's a lot of tater tots in the
room so i wouldn't go just by that
yes it's uh i'm telling you it's so
[ __ ] worth
your time it's grisly and it asks a lot
and it's it's dark it pulls no [ __ ]
punches man takes no prison well it
takes a lot of prisoners but it it it um
it doesn't
spare anything anybody who's like can't
be that hard [ __ ] they're doing
things in this movie it's so [ __ ] up
and sebastian the girl is
wonderful but sebastian stan
is essentially
playing
like a not a psychotic character but a
uh what they call that [ __ ]
where you're like
so she thank you sociopathic character
borderline psychopathic but definitely
[ __ ] sociopathic um charming as [ __ ]
like in a better world
he would be getting a lot of attention
right now for this role i don't see
anybody talking about him in this movie
his he's wonderful in pam and tommy but
he is [ __ ] magical in this movie in a
hannibal lector-ish kind of way where
you're like i hate this [ __ ] prick
but like i would have [ __ ] him too
like
he's just so charming and it is it's a
reverse of the story that like you know
of uh the prey and predator and stuff
like that i'm telling you it's so worth
watching but it goes places
i kept turning to my [ __ ] wife to be
like i i swear i i didn't know like and
she was like no i'm with it now i'm in
and she took the whole [ __ ] ride
it's it's not like i don't want anybody
out there going oh it's some kind of
[ __ ] wokey man bashy [ __ ]
not at all man [ __ ] like it's it's a
horror movie it's a [ __ ] flat out
terrifying horror movie that has an
incredible performance
right at the epicenter of it you know
you need a good villain and this
[ __ ] is
insanely good like you know we all knew
he could be the winner soldier and [ __ ]
but he turned back pretty quickly he was
like steve
um this guy
this guy like i am with you till the end
of the line i'm gonna kill you now like
he's he playing a different bad guy and
it's so worth seeing make the time
to watch uh fresh the title like when i
first heard of it i thought i thought it
was the boazure key movie from 1994
that's what i thought it was i was like
yeah i guess i saw that it's weird like
i i'm sure they were just like you know
oh nobody's gonna remember that movie
but i [ __ ] did and i was like well
why would i watch fresh again but this
is a different fresh all together and
man it's weird are we gonna watch juice
right after that
[Laughter]
that's deep cuts holy [ __ ]
where is camera i keep looking at the tv
and i should probably look at camera
right wave hand
i still can't see you gotta wave even
bigger oh not me all right sorry bang is
that you or
flashlight is camera all right mark so i
am looking at you but you're over there
so i might slip sometimes but i'm going
to try to keep it down the barrel it's
all right i i feel okay you watched
uh i did see i also it wasn't movie was
the premiere of dmz
oh [ __ ] rosario show yes on the hbo
maxes
it was the remake of escape from new
york i didn't know that was coming down
the pike but that's 100 what that show
is
is that what it is it's that's what it
is it's you know
dc comic book right yeah the dc comic
book is much different i mean the setup
is the same that there was there's a bit
of a civil war in american civil war
that the free states of america and the
united states of america and then
manhattan is not a fiction that could
never happen i don't know what you're
talking about but and then manhattan is
the demilitarized zone between those two
buffers
um the comic book is about a
photojournalist guy named maddie roth
who's kind of embedding himself in
manhattan and and trying to to find the
stories of the people who live there the
show is very much about a
medic
that rosario's playing
named alma who's trying to find her son
her son that she left behind when
manhattan was evacuated and she's been
six years on the outside been trying to
get back in finally has a way she's back
in the islands got to track down her son
and and all the while kind of again like
making her way through
the the now kind of lawless
streets of manhattan which still has
communities and still has you know just
people living their lives but it's also
seems to be run by a bunch of gangs one
of which is leaded up by is led by
benjamin bratt who's awesome like
benjamin barrett is always awesome i
always forget how great he is until i
see him like oh [ __ ] you're like really
good at this benjamin bratt
um
i will say that that
this the surprise at the end of the
pilot
of i mean they'll identify like which
character is playing her son that she's
been looking for
feels kind of obvious because you'll see
like oh yeah i bet you that's the kid
and that's the kid but nevertheless like
rosario doing what rosario does and the
film is it's not a film it's a six
episode series i think but it's shot
with like all of the money so for four
episodes four episodes four four
ava duvernay did it right ava duvernay
directed the pilot i'm not sure which of
the other ones she did or if she did all
of them um but it was it was it was
originally supposed to be a series that
then got truncated into a mini series
but i'm here for it like it looks great
it looks great um and it is it's escape
from new york it's a hundred percent
that um and i didn't know how much i
wanted that again but thank you hbo max
for giving me escape from new york but
i texted with her earlier in the week
about something unrelated and she was
like bro watch dmz and i was like is it
dropping soon she's like it's amazing so
she was very very happy with it she
loves doing like comic book stuff that
was one of the things that drew her to
her she was like i've read this so it
was nice to see she got to do it um i'm
going to watch it i can't watch it until
i get home my wife's like you can't
watch it without me
one of my favorite things in the world
is watching the dropout now [ __ ] oh
seafried's performance is so [ __ ]
good and like you know i've watched all
the documentaries on
theranos but
i i i find her performance just [ __ ]
captivating she's not doing an
impression of
uh elizabeth holmes is that her name
elizabeth holmes she's not doing an
impression but she really she's like
chris pine she
evokes
the character she's playing like the way
chris pine didn't just do shatner
but he could evoke shatner and you're
like yeah that's [ __ ] kirk for sure
she's nailed some of her mannerisms and
and the voice thing and stuff like that
but more just the look of law of
constant like i'm drowning and [ __ ] um
but i can't watch that until i watch it
with her and then we just started
watching we crashed
um which is i think also
no that's on apple tv and that's about
the wework thing where jared leto
um is putting on a like a rubber nose a
prosthetic nose and stuff um i don't
know why he [ __ ] bothered like we all
know he keeps trying to cover himself
and rubber this guy and [ __ ]
like could you imagine being that pretty
and you're like make me ugly fast i mean
i guess it being pretty gets boring
because she's like no i don't need it
um it's done all it's gonna do for me
yeah
um
it's uh
it what was i just talking about about
letters we crashed
oh [ __ ] we crashed yeah you know
who's also doing an amazing performance
and he's wonderful in it but she is
[ __ ]
stunning she don't sound
exactly like rebecca newman the wife of
adam newman the guy who ran wework
who you could see in any number of
[ __ ] documentaries
but she is evoking like
like elements or essence of that
character but given a performance that's
like
you know we all know she's great actress
anne hathaway but jesus i'm like
it's so subtle but it's like that person
[ __ ] lives and [ __ ] so we watched
first episode and then i had to get on a
plane to come out here and they're two
more episodes up so i was like i'm gonna
watch those on the plane she was like
you do that we're getting divorced and i
was like
over we crashed like what the [ __ ] you
can stay in jersey for your 69th hike
yeah
i invited her um
so that's what i watched man um i guess
that catches us up on what's happening
now i think so although i did before i
left
los angeles a couple days before i left
los angeles i watched uh no way home
which they released early for like on
itunes and stuff like that i think it
comes out on home video like blu-ray and
dvd
next month but this month they put the
digital versions out you could buy it
like instantly oh yeah how is that movie
you know i don't know if you're familiar
with it but uh let me sell you on this
movie cannibalism no um
it was uh i'm telling you i love that
movie in the theater
but at home like what a fantastic
experience man like i i sat in front of
my laptop um in my office watching it at
like four in the morning until seven in
the morning and had the best [ __ ]
time by myself better time than i ever
have jerking off in that office by
myself i was so into the [ __ ]
adventure it is so much movie
went flying on uh so much movie so
satisfying so beautiful and like
the all the anime stuff like hit me even
harder this time and then andrew
garfield is [ __ ] transcendent somehow
like steals the [ __ ] movie man from
like a very insanely capable cast willem
dafoe's performance i appreciate it even
more this time around first time i was
like yes william defoe it's but he does
this time around like i was like oh and
this time around i did the math
like you know i tried to the first time
i watched it just as a fan right this
time i was doing the math as a filmmaker
gone how many days did they use all
those cats like how many days did they
have willem dafoe and i was trying to
piece it together based on the scenes
and based on the schedule how many days
did they have
toby and andrew um because they they
made productive use
of that [ __ ] time it doesn't seem
like they just shot [ __ ] hundreds of
feet and they're like we hope something
works they got them in and they [ __ ]
like really got down to business with
like the perfect use of those characters
um i will say this is not a complaint by
any stretch of imagination very typical
of any comic book movie but there's no
way in [ __ ] i'll bet my life on the
fact that toby mcguire is not wearing a
spider-man suit up until the shot where
he's like see right here
um other than that no complaints
whatsoever and it made me [ __ ] uh dig
in even double hard where i'm like
there's no way on earth that that movie
didn't deserve at least one of the 10
nominees
kevin
don't do it no don't
are trying to help
hear me out i have something to say uh
sam jackson backed me up and [ __ ] he
said it two weeks later and nobody said
nothing about him well cause he's a bad
[ __ ] exactly it's on the wall
exactly i realized what my cred was zero
but i'm telling you i'm not lobbying i'm
not saying like [ __ ] throw them all
out and some people try to get you where
they're like well what movie should not
be on the list it ain't about that it
ain't about lowering somebody else to
raise somebody else up but i'm telling
you if this ain't
a perfect movie
and i don't mean like a perfect motion
picture like [ __ ] flawless like the
godfather part two or some says [ __ ] i
mean a [ __ ] perfect movie this is
what movies are all about
taking you on an adventure that you are
never gonna [ __ ] see in the real
world i say that as a guy who makes
movies about people that work in
convenience stores and like people who
work at convenience stores see it and
they're like big deal like you know
this is a movie that actually takes you
[ __ ] places and
it's following up like one of the most
inventive comic book movies of all time
with the avengers uh infinity war and
end game [ __ ] saga and still manages
to tell an incredibly original story
while building itself on over 20 years
of previous storytelling by all rights
it should not seem original by any
stretch in the imagination but i don't
know if it was just me but every
juncture
they thwarted my expectation they
pivoted you know when i saw that cast i
was like here comes a sinister six and
it's anything but that and i wasn't i
was not unhappy i wasn't like what the
[ __ ] did they do to the sinister sex
they're woke
not at all man i was like this is a
[ __ ] cool idea for a story instead of
giving me the story i thought i was
gonna [ __ ] get which is the same old
[ __ ] [ __ ] where everybody fights
they found a way where like to really
shine a light on who peter parker is
like you know zendaya has the line where
she's like that's just who he is and
that [ __ ] made me bawl as i was
watching i was like he's such a good boy
why does [ __ ] never work out for him
that [ __ ] him giving up his identity
hit even harder than when i saw it in
the theater way harder man i was so
emotional about that and [ __ ] because it
was such like a sacrifice where he's
like nobody's gonna remember and then i
thought about like how they got away
with that there's no more tony stark
so like that connection is gone and
there's no more aunt may like the two
characters we've been presented with as
the the
touchstones of his life people who would
be like where's peter parker or people
who would try to figure out who the [ __ ]
spider-man is as in the case of the tony
stark
and they're gone and it frees them up to
tell this story where it's just like
he's nobody remembers who the [ __ ] he is
and then he goes to see his two friends
and [ __ ] and he sees that their lives
are i'm gonna get so [ __ ] emotional
i thought it was so beautiful man he
sees their life's going on and he wants
to do what he wants to do
for himself but then he doesn't like
so [ __ ] good my god that movie's
[ __ ] good
that kid's doing was his name john watts
john watts
he's doing fantastic four i know it's
not immediately next but he's he's doing
like some other movie i think i've read
and then he's doing fantastic four yeah
this guy
made me emotional about [ __ ]
spider-man in a way i hadn't been
emotional about spider-man my whole
[ __ ] life i was better than jerking
off with fantastic four
sorry go ahead do you mark no i just
said it's better than jerking off so
yeah you must have been very emotional
well i was in one was shooting webs
either way but [ __ ] this one was less
messy
but my god it was a good watch watch it
again
um
uh when you get a chance like with with
the kids or even by yourself and [ __ ]
like that it's
how many times you see it in the theater
i saw it twice uh twice also yeah i'm
telling you the third i loved it i
absolutely loved it the third home
viewing
like
my heart [ __ ] sword it was just it's
such a transcendent [ __ ] movie and i
know film twitter is like you're a
[ __ ] idiot i know
um but that don't change the fact that
this is an amazing [ __ ] movie uh
regardless
uh all right enough about the past shall
we talk about the future we should
indeed um but i think we should probably
do our second ad before we get there
before we even do the news before we go
here after the news
before we do the q a
it's well you what what do you want to
do kev
i'm here for you i'm here to support you
in your endeavors i thought that's how
we do it is this way
[Music]
let's do the news and then after the
news we'll do the second ad and then
lead into the q a
sounds good
what news you got you know mark bernard
used to be a news man ladies and
gentlemen and even though he left that
world long uh behind uh for the purposes
of this show
he [ __ ] puts on his little cap with
the press card in it and goes back to
work give it up for mark bernardi
bringing you the news
you guys
um did you see and this i'm only doing
this because it doves into a new story
did you see the kenobi trailer kevin
[ __ ] yes
[ __ ] yes and i'll be honest i i even
said in the tweet i put up like i you
know when they announced that show i was
like oh good for you and but i wasn't
like i can't [ __ ] wait obi-wan
kenobi's my [ __ ] like i've never cared
about obi-wan kenobi after that trailer
i couldn't care more about obi-wan
kenobi watching him cuck out little luke
skywalker and [ __ ] like looking at him
that was [ __ ] awesome i had no idea i
should have known that was coming i
fancy myself a [ __ ] writer and i've
seen a star wars picture or two i know
the mythology and yet when they cut to
him [ __ ] looking through his binocs
and they cut to the little luke
skywalker [ __ ] like pretend pod
racing on top of that [ __ ] house and
tattooing i was like god damn it these
[ __ ] know what they're doing
man like that's the perfect blend of old
and new that's a new image a new visual
that i never knew existed in the star
wars universe and it's instantly [ __ ]
indelible
so if they could do that in the [ __ ]
trailer with just that moment and that's
before you get into the inquisitors and
you get into the extension of the star
wars universe to places that you know
cartoons have seen and some of the books
have seen but now the mainstream is
going to see it looks [ __ ]
spellbinding man i honestly like i gotta
learn to
[ __ ] just
bet on them constantly like because when
they announced it i was like eh same
thing like now i'm rethinking uh what's
that next one they're doing caspian or
something like that yeah
i was not i could care [ __ ] less but
after i saw that obi-wan trailer i was
like jesus if they could make that work
maybe caspian will be [ __ ] good too
and [ __ ] cassian not caspian that's a
different thing
than caspian was that other thing wasn't
it yeah the lion witch and wardrobe
thank you ernie ernie grab me a drink
everybody give it up for fernie castle
keeper earning thanks ernie
uh so yes the kenobi trailer
looks [ __ ] awesome what'd you think
of the trailer i think it looks great
you know and i listen i will always go
back to star wars no matter how many
times
i get burned by star wars um
and it's happened a bit
i'll just say
um the minute i hear duel of the fates
the minute i hear john williams music
the minute i see [ __ ] obi-wan kenobi
like yeah like i'm nine years old again
so give it all to me
is that what you said when you were nine
i'm not give me it all give it all
[ __ ] yes
who knew
that episodic star wars
is the best way to ingest star wars i
mean i guess they always did it's always
been like episode 4
episode 6 what they figured out in the
modern era is like just make the
episodes smaller
and then we can make [ __ ] more of
them and [ __ ] less time yeah that looks
amazing who's the the director is uh or
the creator of the show is
uh rebecca ciao
but she did episodes of mandalorian i
believe yeah she did indeed season one
at one point did you know kevin that
darth maul was going to be one of the
bad guys in kenobi
how [ __ ] up is that i read that this
week as well man and a natural you'd be
like oh my god yeah fans will [ __ ]
love that what happened why is it not
darth maul tell him
well um it seems as if there was an
original writer who was working with
deborah chow in the series um
and apparently there was a there was a
time in which ray park was set to
reprise his role as darth maul and it
was an act of prep to do so
but pre-production paused on the series
in early 2020 because lucasfilm was
unhappy with the scripts this is
according to a hollywood reporter story
um the reasoning behind the pause is
more layered according to sources ciao
showed the scripts to star wars stewards
dave filoni and john favreau who were
deep into working on mando season 2.
the first thing they were concerned
about was how much that obi-wan was
going to feel like the mandalorian
namely the lone wolf and cub version of
it where i think those oh the scripts
were tiny [ __ ] luke like i'm gonna
strap him in a rucksack luke and walk
around the jungle and wastes luke where
they were like nope that's a little too
mando for us so we're we're pushing that
aside
and then it was the the mandate was to
make it bigger
and i think that in the making it bigger
they did sacrifice some things namely
lone wolf and cub and b the darth maul
of it all and then filoni specifically
was like i can i think i have no way for
you to get vader into this and i think
there's some things you can lean on from
star wars rebels and the clone wars
namely the grand inquisitors who we see
quite a bit in uh in that trailer
so that's what happened
uh i'm sorry
to be fair i'm glad i'd rather have
[ __ ] darth vader than darth maul any
day
um but oh
i'm sorry i got an opinion bathman's
here ladies and gentlemen give it up for
banff man
i uh i'm just gonna if it went to filoni
he did a wonderful job with
obi-wan kenobi and darth maul having a
final duel in the sands of tatooine kind
of towards the end of star wars rebels
doesn't he get killed he gets yeah
obi-wan kenobi kills him
and then like
but it's like a respectful like he holds
him while he dies at the end of
uh star wars rebels so i don't know in a
world where they're treating clone wars
and rebels as
preciously as they treat all of the live
action i don't know when he probably
read it he's probably like hey we we did
this a couple years ago i don't know if
we need to reinvent the wheel and then i
have to go back and retcon something
that we already did as canon so that
would be my guess
is he's like i did this already and i
think i did it better
could you imagine if you were told like
uh uh look you're thinking too small
with darth maul put darth vader in your
show oh my god i'd be like give me more
notes
um i uh i'll be uh i'm not the darth
maul of it all not being there doesn't
affect me as much
vader having vader and and obi-wan
kenobi in the same show and having
christian uh
hayden christensen come back
is kind of cool as well you know it's
they seem to be
slowly rescuing all parts of the
franchise and uh it's nice that he's
coming back so i prefer it this way yeah
i mean we're we're og star wars heads
you know and so of course our our big
bad is vader but if you grew up and you
and your your star wars was the prequels
then you want more darth maul and
there's a whole generation of people for
whom that's true i'm not one of them so
yeah fine bring me more [ __ ] vader
what else we got
more star wars news ironically enough uh
christopher lloyd is joining the
mandalorian for season three
well that's [ __ ] awesome
that's [ __ ] amazing um of course
nobody knows what he's playing he's not
a member of the cast he's a guest
starring role but um but yeah i mean
he's [ __ ] he's nerd legend and to get
him in star wars
bring it he's been star trek you should
be in the wars too
that's right he wasn't a star trek he
was a [ __ ] klingon who who uh was he
cling on bastard killed my son he killed
kirk's son right yeah
yeah
um so i saw a tweet today i wish i could
remember the author but they were like
now that christopher lloyd's going to be
in star wars
if they don't name his character del
orion
they've missed something
[Laughter]
that's very cute
um yeah man that's awesome i met him at
a con once lovely dude absolutely lovely
dude
who has you know
if he's tired of being told that you're
a huge part of my child that he shows no
sign of that whatsoever and he should
stop doing cons if that's a problem for
him yeah yeah that's true
um speaking of star wars um and speaking
of sam jackson who we invoked earlier he
wants to bring mace windu back
i'm shocked that they have it like
[ __ ] number one sam jackson is
incredibly viable he's [ __ ] you know
the only reason he's probably not back
is because he's off shooting secret
invasion i would imagine
but i can't see how they don't wind up
doing a mace windu something yeah like i
mean there were some folks who who kind
of wanted him to appear
in uh in boba fett
because mace window does kill jango fett
which is the the spark for the boba fett
story oh [ __ ] you're right i forgot he's
the one that kills his dad yeah um so in
an interview with the happy said
confused podcast uh jackson said there's
a huge history of people with one hand
returning in star wars the only person
i've ever said that to about coming back
was bryce dallas howard because i just
did a movie with her and she directs
episodes of the mandalorians so i said
you think you might be able to hook a
brother up i mean you like me right
so yes sam jackson to the whitest women
in the world asked her to hook a brother
up um and she's like i love you you're
amazing so put me back in there sam says
put me in coach i'm ready you know i'll
learn to lightsaber left-handed come on
hook me up
so i can see that happening
sam guess what they want that if we're
hearing about it chances are somebody
had a discussion about it somewhere yeah
it's purple lightsaber
fingers crossed fingers crossed uh
harley quinn
the animated scene you die at the end of
or did he die in revenge of the sith i
mean he's like he fell off a thing and
that never means anything out the window
right yeah but [ __ ] darth maul got
sliced in half and he kept on showing up
i remember at one point during the star
wars movies uh the you know the jj
movies people were theorizing that snoke
was mace windu
wow
because they're both bald i guess
um
i guess i go to the same barber
what else we got
um the harley quinn animated show on hbo
max is getting a spin-off
apparently who which characters um let's
see according to slash film the show is
announced at south by southwest during
the not kidding around warner brothers
animation panel
um the series is currently titled
noonan's
and would center around kite man after
he buys noonan's bar
this is an iconic hangout spot for the
criminal underworld in gotham city and
the location itself first appeared in
the demon annual in 1993. the bar is
named after the hitman sean noonan
yeah it's
the character hitman yes so are they
bringing hitman in
no i don't think so unless it's gonna be
flashbacks to him perhaps
but it's mostly it's mostly a kite man
show apparently
um
see patrick shoemaker their series
co-creator said he tries to run the bar
by himself but it doesn't turn out so
easy
um we have harley and ivy appear in the
first episode but after that we we have
different goons and villains appearing
very much um throughout like lex luthor
and bain it'll be kind of like cheers
for super villains
oh my god
my god man we live in a world where this
is happening where that's like
nobody blinks an eye nobody bats at
night nobody's like oh that'll never
work people like [ __ ] yeah that'll work
i'm delighted that dc is leaning into
the
yeah let him make fun of this [ __ ] like
because you know the original people run
the studio 90s 2000s even earlier than
that would be treated with reverence
like you can't
[ __ ] have jokes you can't talk about
wanting to [ __ ] the joker what are you
crazy and [ __ ] and then harley quinn's
been so successful that they're like
let's make more of these shows um and
they're
it's it's so weird because it's like
something that young
pre-clerks kevin smith would have
dreamed about like an r-rated [ __ ]
version of the of the dc universe oh my
god that will never happen and here we
are in this [ __ ] world i applaud that
idea i think that's absolutely fantastic
i love the harlequin cartoon [ __ ] so
goddamn good um
and that's you know
when you try to do funny for a living
and stuff you're pretty judgy about
other funny and that's one of those that
i like have zero problem doffing my cap
to i'm like my god man the only
like if if there's anything i hold
against harley quinn it's like why
didn't i
think of cursing dc cartoons like that
would have been right in my [ __ ]
wheelhouse uh but man it's so [ __ ]
good i'm happy to hear that that's good
news so good um elsewhere in gotham city
nicholas cage wants to be in a batman
movie
nicholas cage was interviewed on the
south by southwest red carpet for his
new film the unbearable weight of math
it's happened now like
the moment he shows an interest they
should be rolling cameras and [ __ ] yeah
what do you mean who would you see him
playing well he wants to play egghead
[Applause]
literally like this is his quote and
it's it's not like an idol whimsy either
he's like i've been thinking about this
we have the new robert pattinson as the
batman the villain that vincent price
played on the 60s show egghead i think i
want to have a go at egghead i think i
can make him absolutely terrifying i
have a concept for egghead so let them
know at warner brothers i'm down for
egghead
mean how do you not give it to him man
even matt reeves right now should be
like look i didn't think i'd ever say
this but
the batman 2 verse egghead
yes
the mirror
the cracked scene of the batman sequel
and he [ __ ] takes out a terrifying
realistic egghead
with an egg-related crime where he's
like that was excellent i would [ __ ]
oh my god him doing it that'd be amazing
and i never would have thought of that
character because i'm real faithful to
the comics i was like ed ed had ain't
from the comics and [ __ ] i'm glad that
he pulled that idea i hope somebody's
listening [ __ ] yeah i mean it makes
sense like the nicholas cage vincent
price connection seems like strong so
the idea that that's the one he wants to
do
i bite 100 would watch it 100
if he was an egghead which is now it's
gonna be hard to not see him as anything
but egghead but what batman villain
would you
would you cast nick cage as i mean now i
want to see his king tut
while we're at it
give him the daffy's [ __ ] [ __ ] and
see if he can ground it because i
believe if anybody could he could
um hugo strange he would do amazing with
man bat
starface [ __ ] yes
could you imagine he played scarface so
he was the venture the you know the
ventriloquist but also they [ __ ] made
him up to look like the dummy as well
oh that'd be [ __ ] up like remember
that weird pinocchio movie where he's
made of wood and you're like
like that [ __ ] look that's a good
idea scarface see i wouldn't have
thought of that what a great you could
pull that [ __ ] off in a matt reeves
movie right like there's nothing weird
about it's just a guy working a puppet
and [ __ ] like you know which is always
weird kevin
yeah always weird always weird he's got
his hand up a puppetash just making a
talk holy [ __ ] who's a detective comics
alan [ __ ] grant reader from way back
norm bryfogl who said that
[ __ ] man anarchy as a character i
remember when they first introduced that
character i mean i'm sure they've used
that character since but
back in the day that was a norm bryfogl
character i remember buying those issues
off the stand
um well good for nick cage he always
gets what he wants so i'm sure he's
going to get this as well
um you had once earlier in this and by
once i mean like half an hour ago evoked
the performance of one chris pine as
captain kirk
oh [ __ ] one of one of my favorite
performances in movies ever is him doing
his version of captain kirk well we're
going to see another interpretation of
jim kirk
star trek strange new worlds has casted
jim kirk for its second season
now do you what is the premise of
strange new worlds strange new worlds is
the is the enterprise before
captain kirk is the captain so it's
captain
it's number one it's spock
um it's it's the prequel to the classic
series basically and so now they're
introducing in its second season and we
haven't even seen the first season yet
season two is going to have a captain
kirk or maybe just a gym kirk maybe
lieutenant kirk maybe a cadet kirk
unclear but paul wesley
is playing
jim kirk
who is that paul wesley was in the
vampire diaries for a thousand years
um
you think he'd
[Laughter]
some low-key shade there
um do you think uh
like
what does he do did you do the pine were
you kind of a invoke
shatner or do you think he won't shatner
at all
i bet you judging from
um because ethan peck who is playing
spock was on discovery
and uh and he's playing spock very kind
of
subdued like he's not it's not a nimoy
impression it's not a zac quinto
impression it's its own like weird thing
it's very naturalistic so i'd have to
imagine that if that's what spock is
gonna feel like then kirk will also not
be an impression or an imitation of
shatner like i think it's probably gonna
be its own separate thing
where maybe i don't know maybe where's a
hair piece to revoke william shatner
a girl
truckee and somebody who has worked for
the franchise uh how do you feel about
them uh
heading into kirk country i guess you're
okay with it based on the fact they've
done it to spock or is there any
pushback whatsoever i mean i it's it it
seems as if we're kind of backing into
just rebooting the classic series
which in a way i don't know if you need
because it is perfect in its own
incredibly cheesy
like you know
held together with hopes and dreams and
and twine kind of way and like redoing
those stories
feels a bit like a fool's errand so if
they're going to find something new to
do with kirk and spock as young men that
isn't the jj movies that isn't the
classic series then i'd like to see him
try
um but i'm not sure that i'd saddle up
for that particular that's kind of right
i'd like to see him try mark bernard
yeah double darya make it good
um well good for that kid the kid from
[ __ ] fire doctors good for that 40
year old man another job finally
um what's the next story uh the last
story is it's a bit of a rumor which has
not been confirmed by anybody um it must
be true then it must be true um the
rumor is that damon lindelof he have
lost in the leftovers and uh watchmen
could be next in line to tackle the star
wars universe
and that he's currently at work
after his watchman series i i will watch
anything
damon lindelof wants to do including my
wife in front of me
he's a master storyteller you know i
thought when i heard they're doing a
watchmen sequel or whatever a watchman
showed hbo i was like oh naturally
they're going to do it they'll all
[ __ ] 12 books it's going to be the
watchmen story we know then when they
announce it like oh it's not it's a
sequel i was like well this is [ __ ]
dumb why would you ever do that you
perfect [ __ ] material sitting right
there god this is going to be terrible
and it was one of the best
pieces of program piece of media i've
ever watched in my life not just it was
great for that year it's instant [ __ ]
classic and if you love the watchmen as
i did
it's an extension of the story in a way
that makes absolute [ __ ] sense man
it was so magical i was not i've watched
some have lost but i was not a lost
person
um and uh damon's uh
uh the
aliens movie i forget which one it was
maybe prometheus or whatever
didn't really light my world on fire but
like after that watchmen series [ __ ] i
was like this guy could do no wrong man
he could write my eulogy and i'd be
happy to [ __ ] read it um so i look
forward i hope this is [ __ ] true what
would that dude do with a star wars i
don't know but he's a deep deep [ __ ]
fan like i i interviewed him once when i
was back at the hollywood reporter
and was in his office and up on his wall
is the single greatest piece of
memorabilia i've ever seen
which is an original handwritten
john williams score
page for the imperial march
oh [ __ ] yeah like signed by williams at
the end but it was just the [ __ ]
clefs and this this
like all of it i was like that he's like
yeah i know right
like that's amazing in it
[ __ ] you
i'm gonna stage a heist
just for that
um good for him man he did they just he
deserves to do more i was really
at first sad that he wasn't going to go
on with watchmen and then he was like
look i don't have a story to tell maybe
one day i will but like there's no point
in just doing it again because people
because you know they want to fill a
hole in the schedule like i had a story
to tell we told it moving on
uh i respect that incredible restraint
as the guy who just made clerks [ __ ]
three
i was like wow
well well done damon so yeah good for
him i hope they give him a star wars
give him a [ __ ] batman too he's tight
with
reeves and jj and and that's they're all
in that [ __ ] warner brothers world
now but
if he wants star wars naturally give him
star wars i said yeah i mean is his
movie if it's real will join at the very
least the patty jenkins directed rogue
squadron which is still on the release
schedule i thought that was canceled i
mean it's still on their schedule for
december 22nd 2023
so
it feels a little smudgy but
according to lucasfilm and 20th it's
still real
um
you know ryan johnson is still allegedly
working on a new trilogy
um kevin feige is developing a star wars
movie and takeaway tv
nomad land um and and the eternals
director
um
oh yeah
yeah i think she was the one that was
supposed to direct foggy's movie he was
talking about that
not to me like in the press and she
and then taiko ati is working on a star
wars movie also so oh my god give that
[ __ ] guy anything he wants
god he's so [ __ ] creative and fun
look as long as they're doing star wars
the way they're doing star wars lately
i'll take as many permutations as you
got man
like keep it good i'm there for it i see
some people online like don't go for it
i know a lot of people like
[ __ ] on the kids on multi multi-colored
bikes and boba fett they're like oh this
[ __ ] ruined star wars i was like you
apparently weren't there for jar jar
[ __ ] like
[Laughter]
but uh man they're [ __ ] they can't
see they don't seem to miss lately
they're just for me hitting a pitch
perfect
um so i'm looking forward to this as
well
but that's the end of the news weird
[ __ ] concept find talented people and
give them star wars
like yeah
cool
give me one i'd say the people before
what a change but i'm just saying like
that seems to be their new plan
got these toys
and you know if you really like them and
you're talented enough we'll let you
play with them and uh we're going to see
more variety of [ __ ] story because of
it
i mean if they want to know how to keep
me from [ __ ] on star wars
here's a surefire way to do so
give me a star wars yeah
pretty much that simple yeah it's it's
not hard math
is that the end of our news that's the
end of the news my friend
mark bernard he gave me the news
do you know what movie i watched before
i got here today
what
barry gordy's
the last dragon love that movie
it is ridiculous i'm not sure when the
last time you saw that movie was
and i'm not even sure what yeah it must
have been like 83 when it came out
it's awful in all of the most amazing
ways
it's offensive to everybody
right
there's nobody doing anything like other
than than julius carrie who plays
shonoff who's doing a thing nobody's
good in that movie the martial arts
aren't good in that movie the music's
not great in that movie what what are
you [ __ ] nuts man
it's not
it's not i mean you got the glow is a
good song and you save it for the end
sure
but there's a whole lot of cindy lauper
light going on that's not great
but
i watched all of it and then it was on
like tv one which is a challenging even
though i had and it started over again
and i watched it again
and that's when you achieved total
enlightenment indeed that's that's when
i became one with the universe
is watching four straight hours of the
last dragon that's a [ __ ] good tip
man i'm gonna try and if i don't get
through a half an hour and be like what
are you smoking give me [ __ ] some of
that
we got another spot before we jump into
the other sponsor and the q a portion of
the show ashley
gave me a copy of this book that her
friend travis langley wrote it's and
it's relevant to the interests of this
show it's called batman and psychology
a dark and stormy tonight
um
in uh reintroduction is by michael uzlin
who has produced his name has been on
all the batman movies
um and then the intro is by dan the
great danny o'neill dennis o'neill who
has left us
um
does the dark knight have bats in his
belfry why does batman really wear a
costume to fight crime why are the most
intimate relationships with bad girls he
ought to lock up and why won't he kill
that homicidal clown
uh they go deep into batman and
psychology this is an updated version
this book has existed for a while now
but it's an updated version this is the
second edition
um so for all you cats out there
you know that are like i like my [ __ ]
i like to think very seriously about
this [ __ ] here's a whole book
doesn't have a damn [ __ ] picture in
it
we've got about 20 000 words about
[ __ ] how batman is [ __ ] up um
definitely a book worth looking for if
you're into the genre stuff we talk
about here travis langley's batman and
psychology i don't know if you can see
mark but the cover is like a rorschach
inkblock test but you know it turns into
the bat of course ah cute
very cute very cute um the word
associated much with batman cute that's
a free plug man
now here comes the expensive plug ladies
and gentlemen we have our second sponsor
of the evening uh that's going to take
us into the q a and take us home after
that who
has been foolish enough to give us money
this week mark bernardin oh the good
folks at stance
s-t-a-n-c-e
oh my god [ __ ] i love these people
i'm wearing their socks not right now
but like when i go hiking i've been
wearing their socks i wish i'd known
they were the sponsor i would have been
like throw my leg up and be like i'm
[ __ ] wearing it right now they make
socks they make clothing they make
active wear they make a [ __ ] wicked
uh skully cap man which i've been
wearing on walks and stuff like that i
like these stance people but you got the
actual copy what's the address we should
send people to to read along with us the
address we should send people to is
stance.com
and if you use the promo code fatman at
checkout you get 15 percent off your
first order
copy mark what does stats.nbc want folks
to know do you remember how back in the
day sweatpants and joggers were only to
be worn around the house or at the gym
that you couldn't really hey
not you the people
i know you know but that you couldn't
even really be seen around town in that
stuff because it just wasn't cool
but now
stance is making a full line of
sweatpants joggers hoodies and more that
you'll be proud to see wearing whenever
i know personally i got very acquainted
with the sweatpants that i have in my
house over the last two years and i'm
not surprised when i have to wear a belt
but thanks to the good folks at stance i
might not need to actually do that
belts are for losers they're not just
making socks anymore
what
belts are for losers that's for real
that's where we belts
stance apparel is all really soft and
comfortable for next week
yeah
stance is uh really comfortable with
some really interesting designs not the
same old styles that everyone else
offers they have all the active benefits
you want with a casual more creative
aesthetic i'm telling you man they sent
socks and they sent a hat and i've worn
both and they're legit wonderful
i don't wear socks very often just when
i uh go hiking so lately i've been
wearing like socks a lot good for you
and this was like [ __ ] two months ago
and i didn't know they were gonna do an
ad i was just like they like me they
really like me
test their [ __ ] out and i did and it
[ __ ] is legit that i'm telling you is
one of my favorite hats in the world
winter hats so [ __ ] well made indeed
so they're they're not just socks
anymore
what's that they're not just socks
anymore
no they're bringing color comfort and
creativity from toe to head with the
launch of our new active apparel line
that's right what started out as a
radically reinvention of your sock
drawer is now expanding to your entire
wardrobe so check out stance's super
soft liner sweatpants and joggers shirts
and hoodies hats and more which are now
available in a full range of fits
prints fabrics and fun
embrace a life of superior comfort and
creative expression with everyday active
apparel that is truly
stitched different
nice nice i like it good work there
indeed so yeah
whether it's relaxing around the house
working out at the gym running all over
town so they have a lot that we have to
read um stance has got you covered head
on over to stance.com and get 15 off
your first purchase use promo code fat
man at checkout to apply enjoy the color
and comfort of a lifeless ordinary with
stance
stitched
thank the good folks that stands for
sponsoring tonight's fat man beyond give
it up for the good folks at stan
um there was another company that
started primarily in footwear and then
they were like maybe we'll expand and
now the guy shoots rockets into space
and [ __ ]
so the stance people could be on the
same amazonian track could you imagine
did amazon do socks
um all right
ladies and gentlemen
before the show falls apart we are uh
we're going to dive into the q and a
portion of the show
um i don't know how they're going to do
it or
normally we leave this in jc's hands
yeah i'm doing it here tonight
you're the one picking i'm picking i'm
just i'm gonna spot some folks in the
crowd and
inquisit them
um so let's do normally we do three how
about we'll do four okay so i'm on your
side two on my side we'll start with the
cantina
and then uh i'll pick somebody here and
then we'll go
here
all right we ready yes okay uh my man
right here's come on up
all right
hey man what's your name
jason well met jason what's your
question for kevin
yes so
you can't see him kev he's only asking
the question
what there is oh [ __ ]
i'm asking a question jason i won't give
it up for jason he's going to ask a
question
[Applause]
so mark you
you and kevin are forcibly locked into a
room by heath ledger's joker okay he
snaps a pool cue
yeah and tells you which tryouts walks
out
what do each of you do
holy [ __ ]
that is the most serious question we've
ever gotten on this show okay so so i'm
lost after the
fan as well [ __ ] he snaps a pool cue and
he and i kevin and i take a half of the
pool cue
right and so then what's the question
what do we got to do i got to kill kevin
to get out of this room
yeah so it's anticipated
the game oh we're joining the gang so i
got to do some cool ass [ __ ] to join the
gang which may may not include killing
each other
potentially all right it's presumed so
it's presumed so uh all right uh kev do
you have a feeling about what you would
do with your half of a pool cue in order
to join the joker's gang
i'll be honest with you i'm i'm uh i'm a
lover not a fighter so i don't pre-plan
my fights but i do pre-plan my love and
uh this is what i would suggest i would
like to uh
pivot if you will just like spider-man
no way home just when everyone thinks oh
it's going to be this he snaps pool cue
throws it at us and he goes like you
know [ __ ] tryouts and [ __ ]
what we do is we take both ends of the
pool cue not the sharp splintery end but
the other end [ __ ]
lubricate them stick them up each
other's asses
now
now we've changed the conversation
completely
nobody's talking about who's gonna get
killed or anything like that they're
like these guys are great like look at
this [ __ ]
they're working in tandem i mean we need
a partnership or something like that you
know they're calling the joker and
they're like you gotta [ __ ] see this
and he probably jerks off watching us
and then he's like you're hired so i
would say
rather than try to kill each other
because i like mark and i love mark and
i don't think i i don't think i could
land a killing blow even if it meant my
own life and [ __ ] but i do want to live
so rather than just be like go ahead
sacrifice myself like [ __ ] you know
leonardo dicaprio and titanic like only
one of us can fit on the 10-foot door
goodbye
i would say like mark mark let's [ __ ]
stick the pool cues up each other's
asses and see what happens
and i think you'd be surprised by the
results in more than one way
like apparently we're becoming sloppy
bottom party clowns uh yes
to save our lives why not man [ __ ]
i'm not sure i have a better answer that
doesn't involve clubbing you to death
that's your move
what you do is you're like yeah let's do
that kev and then like once you get the
[ __ ] cue up my ass then you stab me
to death with the other cue
and then people like this guy's hardcore
man he will [ __ ] you before he kills you
and that's his friend
or or like there's the version in which
you we both stick the pool cubes up our
asses and then i kill you after that
just because
one of us has got to get in this [ __ ]
club
and somebody's got to die but so the
dude with a pool cue up his ass also
doing murder feels like a really good
job interview
yes
and you'll be guaranteed at least a true
crime podcast out of all of this if not
a flat out dateline episode where you
get sit down by [ __ ] keith morrison
and he's just like oh there's no sitting
down after that kevin
very well done what a great question
just give it up for that question ladies
and gentlemen oh
i have a follow-up oh you have a
follow-up if the pool queue is split in
half
which end
does
goes up the ass is it the rubber end
obviously
the rubber end and the smaller between
the rubber bumper at the end of the
thick end of the stick which to be fair
is thicker than the thin end of the
stick
boy this is a real [ __ ] o henry
problem isn't it like you're damned if
you do damn if you don't um you would
take the you know the tip that you chalk
that goes in one ass and then the handle
goes in the other ass jc come on what
kind of question is that
there are some sundays that one can
anticipate
and then other ones you're debating
which end of a pool cue to shove up your
ass
uh your friends asked but then again
you're also choosing your own ass in the
process so i'm gonna go blue all the way
i go to the point with the the chalk on
the tip and the bell agrees with me i
think i win i'll take the bigger end
because if i'm gonna do it [ __ ] do it
man like
you're gonna [ __ ] me with a pull stick
give me the thick end man i can take it
i want the full experience and [ __ ]
okay
well
jason thank you for your question you
also win a graphic novel adora and the
distance now on sale
give it up for him he won he won mark's
comic book
indeed
uh all right you got one on that end kev
uh no they're gonna win one of these uh
prints by chris mcdonald
do you have a person
i wish i'd brought more weed i could top
you to be like well and you've won one
of my joints
but i need that [ __ ] um
all right uh we need uh to go with a
question the lights are dim
throws in my hands it's gotta be a good
one think about it you know
i can't see faces all i see is hands so
i'm just gonna go like this
straight back wave your hand a little
bit that's you yeah come on up i can't
see who you are but i did see the white
fish belly of your arm
and i'm i'm ready to accept you on to
the show
what's your name oh [ __ ]
give it up for patrick everybody
hi patrick what's going on
patrick just to give you a little
background patrick uh is the son of a
person that i went to school with many
many years ago no it's nicholas
why do i keep saying patrick nicholas
i'm sorry it's the second time i did
that as well nicholas is the son of
somebody that went to i went to school
with me and ernie went to school when we
were kids um if you're in the highlands
area at all
which is the town i grew up in on linden
avenue there's one house that's always
very inventive with their decorations
particularly around halloween and around
christmas um that's nicholas's house
he's way into
horror movies uh
all the all the fun [ __ ] the gruesome
rubber death [ __ ] um he's got a van with
a lot of
you know uh fun weird bumper stickers in
it but he has who's sitting in the
passenger seat uh it's gonna be michael
myers from halloween kills specifically
and then in the back it's shorty from
killer clowns from outer space and
michael keaton's beetlejuice
pretty [ __ ] sweet where do you work
i actually work at spencer's at the
mammoth mall eaton town
checks out what a great job man like
that was the job i wanted when i was a
kid like to work at spencer's have
access to fart cans and [ __ ]
i also work at a spirit halloween during
the summer and then you know halloween
season that's the one i was going for
you're a spirit of halloween kid because
it shows in the front of the house and
stuff
i was walking around highlands while we
were you know doing clerks and stuff and
so in the hike every day
um i would pass uh nicholas's place and
there there was before i made the
connection
i'd pass a van that had a jay and
silabob secret stash sticker on it which
like warmed my heart i was like oh my
god there's some [ __ ] in
highlands who who likes jay and bob how
cool is that
so um i eventually met patrick and he
very much reminds that nicholas god damn
it
you know what i might just get my name
i'm sorry nicholas hey
your name is patrick just to put it in
context i saw
nicholas outside
and i was like oh my god [ __ ]
nicholas i didn't say nicholas i was
like oh my god i said you're in the
[ __ ] credits and he was like are you
kidding me i was like yeah man i made
sure it says patrick right there in the
credits and he was so sweet about not
being like who's patrick
i believe in the credits it's accurate i
believe in my head it's wrong um so
nicholas um
was uh i was talking to nicholas while
we were making clerks three at one point
and i was like hey man roll by on this
night i bet you i can get you into a
scene cause we had real tight controls
with the movie because of covet and [ __ ]
like that we couldn't just have people
walk on set but i was like i think i got
a way to get you in the movie where like
it it won't matter because it's it's
going to be some deep background [ __ ]
show up so he shows up and he's in a
shot in the movie that like i've seen
the movie now
four or five times with audiences and so
i know where all the laugh places are
and and most of them god bless you are
where i intended them but then there are
places where
people did funny things that i didn't
write that [ __ ] got reactions and
[ __ ] this iconic quasi wrote and as much
as i was like go back there and [ __ ]
snap a camera people in the foreground
are doing something that is photo worthy
um every time it's screened that moment
gets a huge [ __ ] laugh and [ __ ] so
when we were putting the credits
together
um like i was looking at the credits
list and i was just like hey man you
know who's not here it's nicholas but i
said patrick patrick's not [ __ ] on
this list and jordan goes who's patrick
goes like patrick's [ __ ] who
like walked by in the background took
the [ __ ] picture everybody laughs at
that moment and she's like patrick
you're like [ __ ] i'll bet my life
it's [ __ ] patrick
i said you gotta get him in the [ __ ]
credits so he's in the credits but i
think you are as nick
makes more sense anyway that's our
background together um that all being
said you were chosen to ask a question
what is your question um so this is
going to be for star wars um
so mark and kevin for the kenobi series
what are you guys most looking forward
to or what do you hope to see in the
series
mark i'll let you go first i feel like
i've been doing tremendously too much
talking
what do i hope to see in the kenobi
series that
well i mean i know there's some things
we know we're going to see right we know
we're going to see darth vader and
obi-wan kenobi have a confrontation of
some sort um otherwise you don't put
those two actors and those two
characters in the same show so
i feel like we're gonna get that the
thing that i do want is i i i want
i want the the kenobi owens scene like i
want the
i'm sorry but uh you know that [ __ ]
anakin
it's my fault like i want kenobi to
admit his wrongdoing and his failings
because you know kenobi is a tragic
character and for him to have to admit
the ways that he's failed
to you know owen
lars
i think it's going to be heartbreaking
and that's the kind of scene that i want
i also would like some explanation as to
how apparently obi-wan kenobi is in
secret for like 40 years
and hiding from what seemed to be grand
inquisitors and and like the [ __ ]
darth vader and [ __ ] but he rolls around
tatooine calling himself ben kenobi like
that works
like oh you mean old ben
kenobi it's like smith or patel there's
billions of us
just ben kenobi that old guy don't know
what you're talking about
so yeah
i like that
about the owen and kenobi thing because
uh i actually just bought these at his
uh comic book store it's one of the
early issues what comic book store is
that patrick
that's uh kevin smith's secrets jay and
selling bob secret stash on 65 broad
street in red bank nice job nicholas
[Laughter]
getting one was intentional man
getting back to what i was saying um i
bought one of the early issues of the uh
2015 star wars run by marvel and um i
think it's issues 7 and 15 if i'm not
mistaken and it's obi-wan's early life
in tatooine into hiding and um there's a
really good scene where uh obi-wan gives
luke i think he tells the jawas to give
luke sky hopper parts because he like
crashes the skyhopper you know while
flying it with his friends bigs and
whatnot and um owen like comes on the
speeder to obi-wan's hut and he's like
really pissed off he's like listen we
don't want your help i don't want you
involved with my family or whatnot and
um it's really i think it's really
emotional because owen says it's one
thing it really gets me it's like having
you killed enough skywalkers already and
it's like wow that's not a marvel comic
yeah that's someone said that to obi-wan
and it's like wow dude that's that's
that's tough that's really rough man
it's over the top
obi wan's like i only ever just wanted
to help and he's like i don't want your
help and it's just so rough you know
it's
it's crazy but also that's also think
cool thing too is a black cranston from
the book of boba fett shows up in the
comics and fights obi-wan isn't that
crazy
so i'm hoping to
see black chewy am i allowed to say yeah
is it what jc what are they what is what
are they what's well it's his name is
chrysanthen because when you say black
cranston i'm like is that like brian
cranston's like brother-in-law
i believe you called him patrick um
can can i answer this i've got an answer
by all means jc
the um the thing i want to see is that
obi-wan doesn't know that darth vader is
anakin skywalker
he left anakin skywalker
dying on fire he thinks anakin's dead
nobody knows that darth vader is anakin
skywalker
i want to see obi-wan learn
that anakin lived
that i think is the the moment of the
show
that is a good answer
that is a good answer [ __ ] it mark gave
a good answer my answer was like i just
want to see uncle owen and aunt peru
[ __ ] and uh
i now that i realize it's on disney
family we're probably not getting that
scene uh but you know i was thinking of
like you mentioned biggs
and that's true we're back on tattooing
with the young luke there could be
a young biggs
running around or if history follows
they'll shoot him and then cut that kid
out all together
i have honestly i had no [ __ ] desire
for this show whatsoever the trailer was
so good i was like oh my god i can't
wait to [ __ ] see this so i have no
improvement no thing that i'm like well
this is what they need to [ __ ] do i'm
the last guy that should [ __ ] listen
to but i think you raised an excellent
point which is like
and and i can't say that filoni and
favreau don't
engage with this some of those [ __ ]
marvel stories from back in the day
like
really legit
work you know it's not just extended
universe it's like this is great [ __ ]
addition to the dialogue of the original
movie and stuff one of my favorite of
the star wars comics was uh the it was
an annual where boba fett got spit out
of the sarlacc pit like something that
we actually saw in the boba fett series
and then he was uh rescued by han solo
but he had no memory of who the [ __ ] he
was and han solo and he teamed up until
his memory was jogged then he was like
solo and he's like oh and he knocked him
in the sword like hole again after they
went off and had a whole ass adventure
so they left him right where he [ __ ]
started and [ __ ] but they took us on
this massive adventure with the
characters that you love um you know
they borrow heavily of course from the
animated series i keep looking the wrong
way they borrow heavily from the
cartoons that they've done that filoni's
worked on but hopefully they've given an
eye toward those comic books a lot some
of those you know maybe not the big
green rabbit crimson jack or whatever
his name is but jackson yes jackson
that's it but um
some of those stories were good and for
those of us
who didn't have multiple star wars
movies and
the option of a star wars tv series that
was it that was like when you were a kid
that was the only extension of [ __ ]
star wars it was either this the
games you played with when you were
playing with the toys or in reading the
comics and then later on like the books
and [ __ ] like that splinter the mind's
eye being the first one
um so hopefully they don't leave those
all behind man um but that's
that's just a sidebar uh that is a you
guys got you guys all gave great answers
i gave a terrible [ __ ] answer but we
got an answer most importantly uh to
nicholas's question give it up for nick
ladies and gentlemen
all right back on this end the last
question over here who we got who we got
who wants to know a thing
[Music]
back against the wall blowing wind out
there big time my wife just texted me
she's like the doors blew open it's a
little breezy it's a little breezy oh
wow that's [ __ ] up yeah so what's your
name sir
who's asking a question we're about to
find out mike hey mike
we'll give it up for mike
what is your question mike all right for
both of you uh if you could revive any
television series ever of all time
what would it be and how would you do it
if we could revive any television series
of all time
what would it be and how would we do it
you know what i wanted to do for the
longest time and once actually tried to
set a meeting to to accomplish was to
bring back uh roseanne because i loved
the sitcom from the 80s roseanne
um i thought it was incredibly realistic
and and i loved the saga of the conners
uh and then they announced they were
doing it i was like elated i was like
holy [ __ ] man the dream's coming true
and then it turned into a nightmare so
um
so i think let me see um
i mean i love news radio but phil
hartman's gone so i wouldn't try to
bring that back and he was an essential
part of it
um
i mean look i for this i would have to
because there's also a part of me it's
like i can't do better than the people
who originally did this [ __ ] like you
know there's things that i was like i
wish they would do another greatest
american hero
but i don't have enough passion to be
like i've got an idea for the greatest
american hero or something like that
um
so i'm gonna go
to my child's heart i'm gonna ask
five-year-old kevin smith
what tv show that he would like to see
rebooted
six-year-old kevin smith would say
laverne and shirley
five-year-old kevin smith would say
batman
so i would do batman all over again i'll
be honest with you [ __ ] it dave mandel
who i did the clerk's cartoon with and
he did uh the kirby enthusiasm with
larry he did uh the movie euro trip um
and he's worked on uh oh yeah he was the
one that [ __ ] wrote that song man
[ __ ] uh scott he doesn't know he's
got it
and he knew we i'm not saying we got it
for him we he knew matt through us and
so that's how matt wound up matt was in
europe at the time shooting i think the
the brothers um grim
and so he was there and they were like
we can write this whole thing can he
play this guy and he came in and cameo
and it was very [ __ ] sweet dave uh
did you know for anybody that loves uh
who's driving bear is driving how can
that be not only did dave write that
joke on the fly dave is the voice as
well he's the guy at the end of clerk's
cartoon he's like thanks for watching
he's holding drinks and stuff um he did
veep for the last few years as well and
he just did this new hbo series about
the white house cleaners i guess during
the you know the uh
watergate era that's going to be on
later this year that all being said
um dave mandel when clerks was coming to
an end he had this incredible [ __ ]
deal he had worked at seinfeld for like
the last five or six seasons of the show
as like one of the main writers and so
when that show ended
every production company in town every
studio swept in to try to get all the
[ __ ] staff and [ __ ] like that so they
had their pick of the litter these
people that worked on the show they
could go make deals for the first time
like writers who didn't create a [ __ ]
show were just writers on a very popular
show people like we'll give you whatever
you want dave got this sick [ __ ] deal
from touchstone tv and they're like what
do you want to do and he's like did you
ever see clerks i would like to make
that as a cartoon then we met dave he
came down to the diner in red bank and
we kind of went through it and [ __ ] like
that so we got to know each other we're
like [ __ ] yeah we want to make a cartoon
uh and then it did not work out the
network canceled us after like the
second episode and [ __ ] but as the thing
was imploding dave had such a good sense
of humor about it all he was mad too
because he [ __ ] loved the show
and this was his first project out the
gate post
seinfeld um and not only did we fail but
we felt so spectacularly canceled after
[ __ ] two episodes replaced with
reruns of the drew carey show at that
point we're still pulling higher ratings
than us so i'll never forget dave goes
um i was like man as a bummer he goes
yeah but the only way around something
like this is to just do something
stupendously different and stupid and i
was like what do you mean he's like i've
been thinking about the show i want to
do and i was like what is it and he goes
catman
and i was like is it based on the dc
captain he goes nope it's just batman
but with a c
and i was like well so what are you
going to do he's like i just want to
remake the batman tv show and i want to
remake it as catman so
everything is exit cat phone cat poles
everything's the same his villainous bat
woman so you know
and i was like oh my god man can you
make that work he's like well i got this
deal at touchstone tv and now that this
is dead perhaps and he went in and
pitched and they did not [ __ ]
they did not see the joke whatsoever i
was like that's so post modern [ __ ]
brilliant but
i wouldn't even do it as irony i would
just be like somebody's like here's a
blank check you got to p there's a gun
to your head you've got to pick a tv
show to [ __ ] remake go i'd be like oh
my god batman like if i'm got a gun in
my head [ __ ] let me go play on the
batman set that'd be amazing
so i would do that absolutely one of the
first things that introduced me to
superheroes batman is you know obviously
a
a pivotal character in my life and and
the idea of being able to
reenact
that which i grew up watching and and
loving you know part of
storytelling
structure
was learned watching
episodes of batman as a kid like this is
how this happens this is a second act
this is a so it's not just like oh i
[ __ ] love batman and the villains
that'd be cool
although that gives you like who do you
cast as the current day villains and
stuff could be amazingly fun
um but at the same time like it's not me
cynically going well this is what the
kids want let's give them that is me
going like i would i would love to go
play in their playground that's when i
was a kid watching their show i'd be
like wouldn't it be great to be in the
show and so to be able to make a version
of that yeah i'd do that in a [ __ ]
heartbeat what about you
um i think i go similar childhood
um maybe a little bit older maybe like
seven or eight years old but i was the
biggest [ __ ] six million dollar man
fan oh
yes i love that [ __ ] show um for no
good reason
other than he's a dude who's bionic but
like the special effects are not good
you know it's just we slow him down to
make him malays running fast
i mean it's it's what can we do in a tv
box such a brilliant bizarro logic like
how do we represent him running fast
like slow-mo yeah like you know what
you're right and for years because of
that growing up i was like really fast
people move so [ __ ]
slow um
that's the closest thing we had to like
a superhero back then we just didn't
have a mask and [ __ ] you know and then
like we would then whatever 40 years
later see versions of like quicksilver
who the way you manifest him running
super fast is by slowing it all the way
down
and it goes all the way back to 6
million man but i think there's like
real
there's real drama to a guy who had
given his life to the service
gets blown up real good and then gets
put back together again using artificial
parts and then what does he think of
himself what does he think of his body
what what kind of
you know body dysmorphia do you have if
your hands are in your hands if your if
your innards aren't real if your eye
doesn't work the way it used to if
suddenly you're seeing parts of the
visual spectrum you've never seen before
if you're hearing way more than you ever
heard before like what does that do to
you how do you find your path towards
being a human again and then whether
you're working for the government or not
i think you want to keep it working for
the government because
he's doing it again like the same people
who put him he was a test pilot so the
same people who put him in a [ __ ]
rocket blaster into a wall or whatever
are now asking him to fight crime while
turning him into a freak like i think
there's there's something really
interesting about that kind of character
and what that character goes through and
then being able to do it for real today
like that bionic dude is frightening and
those powers are immense and insane and
i think there's i just think there's a
lot on that on that tree that you can
harvest from 100 agree when i worked on
the six million dollar man for red hot
minute years ago
it was based on a book called cyborg
by martin kaden i believe the name is
could be wrong on the name but um if
they delved deeply into am i man or
machine in the book so i pulled a little
of that into the six million dollar man
like i was doing like where they ripped
off his other arm to balance him out and
[ __ ] like that and he was like you took
even more of my humanity
so yeah that [ __ ] would be good [ __ ] uh
to [ __ ] go deep diving on
particularly with like a good writer
like yourself and [ __ ]
because they didn't really do that in
the show there was never like you know
an existential crisis that steve was
like am i man or machine he was just
always [ __ ] on the run very slowly
yeah and i don't remember much about the
bionic woman show that was on at this
point now like 20 years ago yeah but i
don't think they
delved that deeply into that either so i
think i think
her injuries weren't nearly as bad as
her she had her legs replaced and she
had a bionic ear i'm not even sure if
she had a bionic arm or not but she
could run real fast and she couldn't
hear every time they would do a close-up
on her ear like
and she would go like this and she heard
[ __ ] like in the other room and you're
like that's bionic um
i can't remember if she had bionic arms
or not though i don't think so yeah but
um they were just i mean could you
imagine they were just like
[ __ ] boyfriend girlfriend parachute
diving and [ __ ]
and [ __ ] you know he's steve austin
who is like steve austin a astronaut a
man barely alive they bring that guy and
save his life put him to work as a
[ __ ] spy he goes out on a [ __ ]
date
he gets the woman he's dating [ __ ]
nearly killed while parachuting out of a
[ __ ] you know plane for fun and [ __ ]
and he turns to the government he's like
do her now
and they [ __ ] do it man like him
they're like well you're a [ __ ] you
know trained test pilot you've got
skills and [ __ ] you've worked for the
government she was a teacher and they
were he was just like do it no like all
right [ __ ] it steve we'll do it for you
six million dollars
into this woman you just met and then
they don't even wind up staying together
man for the purposes of the show they
had to be on two different shows they
weren't even a couple so they had like a
friendly breakup or some sort of [ __ ] so
you're steve austin and you're like i
begged the government to [ __ ] save
this woman's life with all this money
and then she dumped me
turned to the government and like can
you pull the batteries out or something
[ __ ] to be fair
she didn't ask for that
good point
see that's [ __ ] there there's a good
writer right there because that could be
a whole [ __ ] episode or even just the
you know parts of an episode the idea if
she's like i didn't want to be [ __ ]
this like [ __ ] you steve that's why
we're breaking up and he's like i can't
win
he's the charlie brown of cyborgs man
[Laughter]
and then he goes crazy and murders
people
so it's full on brown town
where it's
what was it what was it peanuts with a z
falling brown falling brown
yeah that was a great question give it
up for that question ladies oh thank you
sir
you also win yourself a graphic novel
thank you he's getting a copy of the
book
whoo
making me look bad here in jersey
don't forget everybody we're walking
away with signed chris mcdonald prince
signed chris mcdonald prince um okay
last question could be from this side uh
ladies and gentlemen you know i'm gonna
let
castle keeper ernie o'donnell do the
picking ernie you there
come on up and stage with me so they
could see you in the light ladies and
gentlemen up here on stage they can see
on camera
castle keeper mr ernie o'donnell who
runs uh smog castle here in leonardo new
jersey mere feet away
from uh quick stop which is uh in the
same building when you go see a show at
the scum and villainy cantina you walk
out you're on hollywood boulevard son
right down the street groma's chinese
right down the street from us quick stop
so we gotta [ __ ] it better here
plus you could get killed there i'll be
honest with you
um all right ernie's gonna pick our next
uh question ask her to make it more
democratic man
otherwise i might pick uh patrick
nicholas again
yeah join me up here
come on up sit in the hot seat what's
your name
everyone give it up for sean
[Applause]
it is a little bright um [ __ ] i got a
type man everybody who comes to the show
kind of looks like me in a little way
with a bearded [ __ ] like that um sean
what do you do
oh nothing yeah yeah unemployed
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] hey so [ __ ]
we're damned interested in what you have
to say what is your question my friend i
just uh re-watched battlestar galactica
and this time the series the whole
series yeah and this time i did it with
the podcast with mark and trisha
and um i wanna know he like talked about
it at the end uh
have you watched something that like or
he talked about a story with his mom
like going to the art with the museum
has you watched anything or we watched
anything that like has inhibited a
different uh emotion over the years
what a great question did you get that
mark
i did is there anything that i've
watched
re-watched and the experience of
re-watching it now has hit me
differently than it did the first time
that's correct got it yes um yeah
[ __ ] spider-man no way home i told
you at the beginning of the [ __ ] show
uh no aside from that let me think i
feel that way about music quite often
because you know my whole life
my my uh father when i was a kid he was
a big country and western fan which was
so crazy because we weren't even from
there was no south about us we weren't
even from south jersey you know so the
fact that he liked that music always
drove me nuts because it was my least
favorite kind of music
and he would sit in his bedroom and sing
the top of his lungs these country
western songs and [ __ ] and as a kid it
would irritate and fascinate me because
that irritate because they're like i
hate all this music fascinate me because
this is the only time i ever saw my
father break in to song he wasn't that
guy would walk around the house singing
and [ __ ] he'd close his door put on his
[ __ ] records and he would just sing
his [ __ ] heart out and that was
probably his release probably he's like
the only way i can deal with that
butterball of a child of mine is to come
into this room and sing at the top of my
lungs
so when my old man died um wouldn't you
know it
i started liking country music not
enough to be like and now i [ __ ]
listen to all of it not at all but
that was a tie to my old man
and instantly it went from that thing
that he used to do that irritated me to
the thing i'll never hear again and now
i regret that i judged it because there
was that was the guy
free as [ __ ] like you know he spent most
of his life in service to his wife his
family prior to that his parents and
[ __ ] like that and he was freest you
could tell when he was in a room singing
along to you know [ __ ] hank williams
jr
at the top of his his lungs his soul on
display it was really beautiful
so i'm familiar with the notion of this
thing and then suddenly this thing
one of those movies for me
was and it's
very strange but uh the talented mr
ripley matt damon movie that was
directed by um anthony mangela when the
first time i saw it i was like there's
[ __ ] pretty people doing simple
things [ __ ] this movie
next time i saw it for some reason i was
like oh my god this is so [ __ ] tragic
and sad this character is fascinating
like he's so broken
and
and yet he's
he's it's his fault he's [ __ ] at the
center of it and stuff i've watched uh
the talented mr ripley
honestly no not even bullshitting 250
times like since since like uh i married
jennifer uh it became a big go-to movie
for us where it's like what do you want
to watch couldn't figure anything else
be like ripley ripley and we watch
ripley [ __ ] you know philip seymour
hoffman was like tommy how's the peeping
tommy he's got cool [ __ ] moments in
it but
i definitely
re
i had a different take on that movie
than the first time i i saw it but it
was not that wasn't predicated on
emotion let me see if there's anything i
ever want you know what i'll think about
it while mark tells an answer i'm going
to think if there's anything i ever saw
that changed emotionally when i saw it
the [ __ ] next time go ahead mark
um
yeah i mean my my easy answer would be
battlestar galactica because i've
already done that um
but i think a lot of it has to do with
a change in your own personal life in
the interregnum from when you first
watched it to later and the easiest way
for me to demarcate that is here's when
i had here's when i was a single dude
without children to watching it again as
a married person with children
and you know for me
i think it was it's it's so random but
there's this great scene in conan the
barbarian which meant nothing to me
for decades and it's when max von cedar
was king osak is talking to sandal
bergman and arnold schwarzenegger as
valeria and conan the barbarian about
um doing a job for them
like you you seem to have defied the the
snake gods and the whatever and i want
you to steal some [ __ ] and why
and then
what osric says is you know there will
come a time thief when when gold ceased
to when gold loses its luster when jesus
not there will come time there comes a
time thief
fair there comes a time thief when
jewels cease to sparkle well gold loses
his luster when the throne room becomes
a prison and all that's left is a
father's love for his daughter
and like that line was just like cool
[ __ ] that max von cedar says because
he's [ __ ] cool but then as you get
older and as you have children
specifically and as you have daughters
the idea that there's nothing you
wouldn't do for them becomes manifest
and real
and it's just a dumb little moment in a
dumb little movie but suddenly it became
like oh
i see what that is i see why he's doing
what he's doing because he just wants
his kid back and he will do anything to
do it and he's tried a hundred different
ways and nothing's work and now it's
[ __ ] desperation maybe this hulking
lunking barbarian can do what nobody
else can do
and so it's just it was that feeling of
there is no depth to what i will do for
my child that i couldn't understand
until i had children
[ __ ] beautiful right
you got a cool out of them yeah cool
cool
um
i mean i i
i ain't gonna top that that's a
beautiful answer give it up for mark
bernard and everybody
um
but we don't get to a beautiful answer
without a great question give it up for
my man everybody excellent job excellent
job
[Applause]
um
i was i was trying to think of an
example and i really i can't think of
one it's more in music than anything
else
um but not movies like very rarely that
i see a movie that i don't like and then
come to like later on or vice versa it's
never gone the other way where i liked
the movie and then didn't like it or
something although fairly recently and
when i say recently i've been meme
within the last five years i think i've
talked about this before
um i realized oh my god [ __ ] my kid
has grown up already and we never
watched labyrinth i meant to watch
labyrinth with her and she's 20. you
know so i did we just missed it we
watched a lot of things for some reason
we never watched labyrinth and i dropped
a labyrinth reference to her i was like
and she was like what is that and i was
like [ __ ] labyrinth she's like what's
that and i was like we never watched
labyrinth what a terrible father i am so
i
i sat her down at age 20 and we watched
labyrinth together and about 25 minutes
into the movie i had this real sinking
feeling where i'm like she's not really
engaging with this whatsoever i'm about
15 years too late in showing her [ __ ]
labyrinth she's like it's well made
you know it was like that was her her
compliment but you know i thought the
magic of labyrinth would [ __ ] grab
her and stuff but
i i'd missed the [ __ ] window man it
was a real [ __ ] cats in the cradle in
the suit
kind of [ __ ] moment
um we're out of questions is that right
we are i do have one little public
service announcement ooh let's hear that
um this comes it was left on the bar for
me uh it says it's my birthday this week
uh 3 25 and all i can ask for is a shout
out for the homeless outreach non-profit
the center in hollywood for our upcoming
annual charity hike the hollywood hike
for the homeless on april 2nd many
thanks and continued success jason brown
happy birthday
jason well done jason good looking out
the noble work when is the hike because
i'm something of a hiker mark not
professional but i do dabble i've heard
you've done at least 69 of them
yes
uh the hollywood hike for the homeless
is on april 2nd
does it say where it is just all through
hollywood or in the hollywood hills
elevating the register you register
today
at
bitly.com
center hike it's in griffith park
oh [ __ ] that's pretty it's really pretty
it's not gonna matter to everybody here
in jersey but it's uh
it's very pretty out there there's a
nice place it's a 7 30 a.m rally 8 a.m
uh hike kickoff
so yeah there you have how many people
out there like thinking with their
hearts and not their heads man like
that's really awesome to hear somebody
put together something like that on
behalf of somebody so yes and happy
birthday jason
happy birthday jason give it up for
jason center at hollywood.com
excellent um is that uh jc do we have
anything left or is that it that's it
for us the end of our show
that's it
that's it i can't believe did we stay
online the whole time we stayed online
the whole time holy [ __ ] the technology
works that may be a first um what uh
what about we were you i know you were
busy doing andrew's job this week did
you get a chance to look at chat while
it was going on i did
it was pretty good people liked the uh
the coast to coast show they like this
better than the zoom
ah
oh well i'm glad they like it it'll
never happen again
this is something we do just in case of
emergencies people like no we prefer
this to the real thing
um i'm glad uh folks were able to come
out tonight man uh first off uh let's
give it up uh for jc banff man himself
the scum and villainy cantina
when in hollywood right on hollywood
boulevard kids if you ever want to get
drunk in a star wars bar around friendly
people who will never fight you that is
the place to go however if you're sober
and you're like i don't need to be
around booze at all welcome to smod
castle kids
the dry is a [ __ ] bone because it's
250k for a liquor license so
any snacks you want right down the
street at quick stop they don't sell
beer either so you're [ __ ] byob as we
say um but uh we don't got no smog
castle uh without the man who runs and
give it up for smart castle keeper ernie
o'donnell
[Applause]
um
i'm sure you know back there in the
cantina jc's got cameras stationed at
all times
here we got lucky because chuck came out
to shoot for us tonight give it up for
chuck everybody he's on the camera good
job chuck
[Applause]
and uh my jc slash uh andrew uh the man
in the in the chair the guy in the side
booth who made sure that you could hear
everything and whatnot is christian give
it up for christian everybody
[Applause]
but
[ __ ] all them there is no show
without the man
sitting way over there in los to my left
but the left coast all together give it
up for the marvelous mark bernard ladies
and gentlemen
thank you
and that my friends is fat man beyond
for this week
there we go that makes more sense that
my friends is fat man beyond am i
covering you know are you clear you're
good that is fat man beyond for this
week i'm kevin smith i'm mark bernardin
tune in next time same fat time same fat
channels podcast.com or youtube.com
kevin smith jeff's kiss everybody wow
good night
los angeles
we did it
we made it happen
[Applause]
this is the cat
greetings everybody
and welcome to the
aka ask if anything every saga has a ten
year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith